welcome back McDonald's faces a new wave
of accusations from women who claim they
were sexually harassed on the job and
those women are getting some
high-profile support from Hollywood 25
additional complaints were announced
yesterday and protests and advocates
have been inspired by the me2 movement
and they are now backing these claims
Niki batiste is outside a McDonald's in
New York where no doubt the morning rush
is on Niki good morning Tony good
morning
studies show why McDonald's is a prime
target of these complaints according to
one national survey 40% of female
fast-food employees say they were
sexually harassed at work 42% of them
felt forced to accept it because they
couldn't afford to lose their jobs
McDonald's employees and activists
marched toward the company's corporate
headquarters in Chicago Tuesday many
taped their mouths shut before breaking
their silence
Jamelia Farrelly is one of more than two
dozen workers who have filed complaints
against the company she says a male
co-worker repeatedly touched her
inappropriately and managers cut her
hours after she reported the abuse
during the alleged victims are getting
legal support from the ACLU and The
Times up legal defense fund created in
the wake of Hollywood's me too movement
to help women at all income levels who
face harassment support is also coming
from politicians and big-name stars
including Kerry Washington Reese
Witherspoon and actress Mira Sorvino who
tweeted tell McDonald's we're not loving
it
celebrity chef Padma Lakshmi attended
Tuesday's protest does McDonald's care
more about selling Burgers and Fries
than it does about making sure its
employees are safe on the job in a
letter McDonald's says it's committed to
providing a safe and respectful work
environment for all and is implementing
new training on harassment and offering
a hotline for reporting complaints the
ACLU says the fast food chain has faced
more than 50 similar charges and
lawsuits in the last
three years last September workers and
ten cities walked off the job to protest
rampant sexual harassment employees at
Tuesday's rally say they hope their
complaints will finally lead to change
my morning I had anxiety just thinking
about having to work at McDonald's
I lost my joy in my dignity in the US
alone McDonald's has about 850,000
workers at about 14,000 restaurants more
than 90 percent of those are
independently owned franchises the
company has long argued that it should
not be liable for how employees at those
locations behave Gayle all right Nikki
batiste thank you very much it's such an
important conversation it's really
touching on all aspects of these 150 40
percent the fast-food workers across the
industry report harassment on the job
and people are listening